[Música]
el punto de partida de esa domesticación
es la concepción de que el niño es un
alumno
del griego a alumnos sin luces es un
pobre ser que vive a oscuras y al cual
los maestros lo iluminan necesita ser
iluminado desde afuera porque el en sí
mismo está en la más absoluta oscuridad
se trata por tanto
de domesticar de instruir de llenar de
conocimientos que se supone quien supone
supone el estado suponen las
generaciones anteriores una serie de
conocimientos que niños y niñas van a
necesitar y que sabemos por experiencia
que en la práctica en la mayor parte de
los casos nunca necesitan entonces el
proceso de domesticación escolar
incorpora elementos básicos como lectura
y escritura como básicamente cálculo
supuesto aprendizaje de algunos valores
y por encima de todo del valor de la
obediencia
al niño en la escuela se le obliga a que
aprenda esto porque porque no digo yo
que soy el maestro disc a mí no me
interesa no importa ahora toca lección
32 los ríos de áfrica y está los
aprendes y si no me interesan igual
pierdes el tiempo
se trata
de qué
se supone que la sociedad adulta sabe lo
que nuestros niños niñas y jóvenes van a
necesitar para defenderse en la vida
cuando en realidad la vida avanza mucho
más rápido que lo que somos nosotros
capaces de calcular y nunca nadie sabe
que es lo que van a necesitar nuestros
actuales niños cuando sean personas
adultas
el resultado de esa escuela
domesticadora instructiva supuestamente
ganadora de conocimientos
el resultado es el aburrimiento
el aburrimiento la desmotivación la
decepción y si no a ver porque ha sido
necesario conveniente que este gobierno
invente el bono juancito pinto
es un poquito de plata para que gracias
a esa plata los niños no caigan en la
tentación de desertar y dejar el curso
antes de que terminen
es una prueba de lo aburrida y
frustrante que es nuestra educación
sistemática cuando nuestros niños
tenemos que comprarlos con un bonito
para que se animen a terminar el curso
ahora dentro de este sistema
mundial la única excepción que yo
conozco es el estado finlandés
el resto del mundo practica esa
educación instructiva domesticadora
etcétera y dentro de ese sistema por
supuesto puede haber diferentes niveles
nosotros aquí en bolivia estamos
probablemente en uno de los niveles más
bajos
yo me atrevo a afirmar que lo he dicho
en muchos lugares que hoy día el 70% de
nuestros bachilleres no saben leer
por supuesto no es un culpa no les hayan
enseñado a ver estrellas les han
enseñado a repetir les ha enseñado a
memorizar no les han enseñado a pensar a
fondo a ser críticos
y a ser creativos
en cambio en el otro extremo puede haber
países con sistemas exactamente iguales
en la concepción pero con un nivel mucho
más profundo y eficiente el caso más
espectacular es el de la china hoy día
pero hemos visto películas referidos a
la educación en china que nos muestran
que junto a ese alto nivel de
conocimientos a lo que lleva es al
incremento anual de los suicidios
infantiles en china porque a los niños
se les amarga la vida se les convierte
en un desierto son niños que envidian a
sus papás porque pueden ver la tele
ellos no pueden no tienen tiempo no
tienen cuándo
y ahí la imagen de un niño que se ha
metido en un concurso y logra ganarlo la
madre del niño expresa felicidad la
educadora del niño expresa felicidad y
el niño como un zombie ni se entera de
lo que ha pasado
entonces ese sistema es deshumanizante y
si encima si encima además tiene poco
nivel como pasa en nuestro caso es mucho
más preocupante
frente a eso lo que cabe es la promoción
de modelos alternativos de educación yo
abro expresamente de un modelo concreto
que se llama la comunidad eco activa q
sic una
donde lo central es la convicción de que
el sujeto del proceso educativo es el
niño o la niña o el adolescente
el maestro educador es un estimulante
que es un acompañante
es un
una fuente también de información y de
recursos pero de ninguna manera es el
que me marca la vida y el que me dice
eso tienes que aprender y lo tienes que
aprender así y lo tienes que aprender
ahora es que no quiero no importa
al revés el maestro el educador es el
qué
acompaña nunca domesticando se no
siempre apoyando y promoviendo el
crecimiento de cada niño y niña de
acuerdo a sus ritmos personales a su
personalidad específica a sus
experiencias de vida a sus procesos
concretos de vida que no son iguales ni
siquiera en el caso de dos hermanos de
la misma familia cada uno tiene sus
rasgos sus procesos y se trata de
respetar eso y de aprendiz a partir de
ahí sí iniciar y avanzar en un proceso
de aprendizaje pero que no está
condicionado por lecciones
manuales libros concretos que hay que
seguir tareas
sino que está condicionado por el
crecimiento personal y el desarrollo
personal de cada niño y cada niña
esto incorpora el conocimiento crítico
de la realidad y por tanto la
importancia de la investigación
es increíble como nuestras guaguas si se
las dejan libres y se las estimula están
en condiciones de investigar desde
chiquitos en nuestra escuela hemos
tenido un proceso muy bonito entre los
niños de 1º y 2º de primaria hacían por
ejemplo una investigación sobre las
mariquitas y ellas y ellas se
preocupaban de ver cómo funcionan qué
hacen qué comen de qué viven quienes son
sus sus posibles enemigos etcétera y
quien dice eso dice otro montón de temas
que tienen que ver con la naturaleza es
otro elemento fundamental de cualquier
aprendizaje serio la vinculación con la
naturaleza con la realidad con lo que
pasa
pero que además tienen que ver también
con las ganas y la vocación de cada niño
y cada niña se trata de aprender en lo
posible haciendo y no repitiendo de
aprender practicando de aprender
ensayando de aprender investigando de
aprender equivocándose y comprobando
después donde estaba la equivocación y
no de aprender memorizando porque es la
lección 32 y ahora toca y voy a dar
examen y después del examen me olvido de
la lección y me olvido de todo y no pasó
nada
en un sistema así en un proceso así
educativo juega un papel informe
fundamental el juego
y padres y madres de familia clásicos
claro los pobres han sido también
víctimas de un proceso educativo de
alarma en cuando ven que sus niños en la
escuela se pasa horas jugando cuando
precisamente el juego es un elemento
que ayuda a la socialización que ayuda
al relacionamiento con el otro que ayuda
al desarrollo de la propia capacidad
motriz intelectual imaginativa creativa
entonces el juego de por sí es educativo
siempre y cuando ese juego esté
acompañado presenciado etcétera por
educadoras y educadoras que tienen la
preocupación de saber cómo y en qué
momento nuestras niñas y niños crecen
mejor y más seriamente
también tiene una importancia especial
la relación con la naturaleza por eso
nuestra escuela se llama comunidad eco
activa activa pero activa en relación
ecológica con la naturaleza con el agua
con la tierra con la lluvia con las
plantas con las flores con la basura
con el uso de los desechos
es decir la vinculación con la
naturaleza la preocupación por los
componentes ecológicos de todo qué hacer
y de toda actividad humana son parte
esencial de una educación que responda
al objeto profundo del proceso educativo
que es la orientación mejor más cabal y
más fecunda de cada persona en su
sociedad en su quehacer en su mundo en
su vida en su país no es igual la
educación en bolivia que en la india no
puede ser igual
el aprendizaje además tiene doble
sentido si va compartido con la familia
si es un aprendizaje en el que la
familia también se involucra a la que
también le interesa y no solamente el
niño que vaya a la escuela y quedamos
libres del mediodía y en su día llegará
pues suficientemente capacitado para
ubicarse en la vida no es así la familia
está a cork kondik convocada a
participar seriamente en el proceso
educativo de sus niños y niñas claro que
si no lo hace o no lo puede hacer no
está todo perdido se puede suplir pero
nunca es igual la participación de la
familia que es una participación
juega otro papel importante también la
interculturalidad y la inter capacidad
diría yo la interculturalidad tiene que
ver con el relacionamiento permanente y
cotidiano con niños niñas adolescentes
amigos amigas de otras culturas que
pueden ser nacionales en nuestra escuela
tenemos familias que ellos lo aymaras
pero también pueden ser internacionales
y eso también es sumamente saludable
aprender a convivir con niños cuyos
papás o alemanes o franceses o mexicanos
o peruanos
y la inter capacidad
un principio fundamental de una escuela
como la nuestra es la presencia de niños
y niñas de alguna manera especiales
con síndrome de dawn por ejemplo con
formas de retraso mental con distintas
formas de autismo primero para ellos una
escuela así relajada activa amistosa es
mucho más adecuada pero segundo para el
resto de los niños es sumamente
importante y educativo el aprender a
convivir con niñas y niños diferentes el
aprender a valorar lo que tienen que
todos tienen cosas valorables el
aprender a a
a compartir también tiempo iniciativas y
propuestas con ellos y aprender a ser
amigos de ese tipo de chicos y chicas
en resumen
lo que nos parece importante
en un proyecto educativo como este no es
tanto las cosas que se aprenden que
están en todos los libros y lecciones de
todas las escuelas del mundo sino
aprender a aprender a aprender que lo
que haga falta lo que ese niño o niña va
a necesitar en la medida en que vaya
siendo joven en que vaya siendo adulta y
no se trata de que la regla de tres es
fundamental depende pues si encuentras
un momento en que necesita la regla de
tres la aprendes y si no pues no la
aprendes y no te pasa nada como no nos
pasa nada a todos los que nos hemos
olvidado de la regla de tres que
estudiamos en la escuela y que después
no hemos usado se trata de aprender
a resolver problemas a trabajar en
equipo a investigar
y por supuesto aprender las cosas que
requieras
que en la práctica
son muchas menos de las que nos
pretenden enseñar en las escuelas de
este país y de todos los países con
excepción como digo de finlandia y
finalmente me parece importante acotar
que este respeto a la diferente
personalidad a las diferentes
circunstancias a los diferentes procesos
de vida y a las diferentes vocaciones y
capacidades de cada niño y cada niña
no implica
el fomento del capricho ni de la
arbitrariedad el respeto a la libertad
tiene que ir acompañado del
establecimiento de límites
formar en libertad lleva consigo formar
en responsabilidad tu has escogido eso
ahora tú respondes de eso que has
escogido tú te organizas y no vale que
digas no ahora ya no me interesa tú no
has escogido querido libremente por
tanto ahora lo haces ese ejercicio
combinado de libertad y responsabilidad
de asumir compromisos y cumplirlos y de
respetar límites básicos
no vale golpear a nadie no vale insultar
lo que se desordena se ordena lo que se
ensucia se limpia y lo que digo lo que
se planifica se cumple todo eso es parte
esencial de un programa educativo
realmente diferente
[Música]